Longtime fans of "The Witcher" video
games are sure to recognize an early
game character in the third season of
"The Witcher" on Netflix. They'll also
notice that things go very differently
for the character this time around.
At the beginning of "The Witcher" Season
3, protagonist Geralt of Rivia encounters
a peculiar, refined mercenary who goes by
the moniker Professor. Unfortunately for
the bespectacled wannabe assassin, the
meeting is as brief as it is violent,
as Geralt dispatches the Professor after cutting
through his men with the greatest of ease.
"I importune you. Forgiveness, sir?"
The Professor's foray into the world
of Netflix's "The Witcher" is so swift
that people who aren't familiar with the
games might wonder why the character is so
elaborately designed. The reason is simple: The
antagonist's appearance is a massive Easter egg
for fans who have played the very first "The
Witcher" game from CD Projekt Red in 2007.
The Professor makes multiple appearances in
the game, and as players can no doubt attest,
he's a far bigger challenge for Geralt
than his Netflix version proved to be.
The ease with which Henry Cavill's Geralt
dispatches an enemy who gave his video game
version such trouble is a sign that by the third
season, Netflix's Geralt is the legendary Witcher
at the height of his powers, and could just
be the most powerful Geralt we've seen so far.
That's not to say that the Professor is
anywhere near the strongest antagonist
Geralt has to carve his way through in the
games, but the assassin is nevertheless
a formidable challenge whom the Witcher
faces more than once. He's a condescending,
snide man who isn't afraid to rely on underhanded
tactics like wrist-mounted crossbows and powerful
protective spells. The Professor also shows
very little fear while fighting Geralt,
and isn't shy to lecture the protagonist
about his views on the subject of Witchers.
"You were meant to slay monsters, without making
judgments, philosophizing or nursing doubts.
You're ineffective."
Apart from being a brief nod at the people
familiar with the first "Witcher" game,
the assassin's presence in the Netflix show
is also a fun meta-joke of sorts. Because
the Professor is one of the two first major bad
guys Geralt encounters in his very first game,
with the other being Azar Javed, he can be
viewed as something of a starter villain. Here,
he's pitted against a considerably stronger
and more experienced Geralt, and the power
imbalance between the two is not unlike what
would happen if a video game character returned
to the first area of a game after maxing all
their stats. Thanks for dropping by, Professor!
There's another key reason why the Geralt from
the games may have had a tougher time with the
Professor, apart from the differences in his sheer
skill and power. In the first "Witcher" game,
Geralt is dealing with far more than the usual
world-ending threats and man-eating monstrosities;
he has also lost his memory. This
Geralt is more or less a blank slate,
and still a long way away from the
dominant, intimidating fighter he
once was or would become again by the time
the third "Witcher" game rolled around.
The live-action Geralt, on the other hand,
might be struggling with his emotions,
but his memory is fine. So are his fighting
skills, his knowledge of Signs, and all the
things that make him such a formidable opponent.
This Geralt also meets the Professor in a random,
muddy backyard, while the game versions
of the characters contend in situations
where the Professor has an upper hand. At one
point, he leads an assault against the Witcher
base Kaer Morhen, and in others,
he's protected by powerful magic.
Still, let's be honest -- even if the
Professor had brought his full bag of
tricks in the Netflix show, it's unlikely
that he'd last long against this driven,
resourceful, and tougher-than-ever Geralt.